hello hello hello hello how's everybody
doing welcome to beautiful shadow creek
my name is Adam luff co I am with
Bleacher Report and of curse the Turner
family and I am thrilled to be hosting
this press conference for Capital One's
the match gonna be very honest with you
I'm a little bit more excited for Friday
November 23rd you know the time noon
local 3:00 Eastern I'm gonna be hosting
the pregame show that starts at 11:00
local to Eastern that is myself Pat
Perez Charles Barkley and samuel
l.jackson it is going to be awesome but
the main reason it's going to be special
the two golf icons the reasons that
we're here today historic match 19 major
championships between them two hundred
million dollars plus earned and I only
need to say their two first names and
you know how special this is it's Tiger
and it's Phil it is a first-of-its-kind
pay-per-view event match play format
nine million dollars winner-take-all but
if you know tiger and you definitely
know Phil the side action is going to be
flowing granted it's going to charity
but that pride cannot be taken back both
golfers are going to be miked both
caddies are going to be miked and when
it comes to broadcast production you're
gonna see things for the first time in
golf that you've never seen happen
before I really want you to hear this
from tiger and Phil and you're gonna
hear them in just a second but first I'd
like to turn it over to the main man the
super stud David Levy the president of
Turner for some opening remarks I don't
think I've ever been called a stud
before let alone super stud thanks Adam
Thanksgiving in Las Vegas that's always
been on my bucket list and now I can
check that one off at turning across of
all Warner Media we are thankful to be a
part of this event between these two
icons I'm sure all of us can't wait for
them to tee it off this Friday event of
this nature does not happen without a
number of key stakeholders and on behalf
of my colleagues
I want to acknowledge and thank a few
individuals it took a tremendous amount
of vision collaboration and creativity
to make this historic match a reality so
first I'd like to thank Mark Steinberg
and the entire XL sports management team
Steve Lau and everyone at La Adair
Sports je Monahan the PGA Tour
Commissioner Monty Montgomery our MGM
partner and all of our friends at CAA
and of course John stanky the Warner
media CEO as well as all of my
colleagues who helped us put this
together at the Warner Media family in
addition adult lights acknowledge my
turner sports team who are away from
their families this week to help bring
this event to life they really truly are
the best in the business this event has
captured the imagination and interest
interest of so many I'd also like to
thank our title sponsor Capital One and
our associates and sponsors outtie and
AT&T ok tiger and Phil need i say more
we all know the history between these
two champions and also the competitive
Flair they both have and that's why we
believe that this event will be one for
the ages it's also the very reason why
Turner and Warner Media wanted to be a
part of the match this event is the
first of its kind worldwide distribution
agreement for Turner and the newly
formed Warner media it will be offered
live on pay-per-view
this Friday coming from outlets Turner
be our live
AT&T DirecTV and AT&T Universe as well
as a number of other cable satellite and
telco companies before we bring out our
two competitors let's take a look at our
two great champions
when in the amateur was one of the
greatest thrills of my life tiger and
Phil they started winning and dominating
when they're 10 years old I'm really not
that famous yeah if I can get on tour
and then do well then I'll probably why
is victory so tell my caddy the hook the
gallery gets bigger I love competition
I might be playing against Phil
Mickelson another chapter and
Mickelson's daring life of golf it's how
much I hate to lose that drives me least
one held competitor I find a way to
score it find a way to shoot a number
still Mickelson
47 has done it again
we play our best ball is totally
definitely when Phil's on he is not
afraid of tackle it's not a single shot
that Phil sees that he feels like he
can't pull Tigers game is greatest of
all time why don't we just go head to
head
definitely not against that it's gonna
be fun
everyone it's my pleasure to deduce two
golfers that combined have 19 majors
between the two of them ladies and
gentlemen
Phil Mickelson and Tiger Woods
[Applause]
hey guys doing I've heard about you guys
a lot recently
welcome Tiger Phil I'm just curious I'm
gonna start you guys off here how did we
get to this moment do either of you want
to take the credit for this how did we
get to this spectacle it was I guess
some conversations that took place right
after I won Mexico the very following
week he likes to show me up and
everything he does and he's out leading
at Valspar and the conversation kind of
took from there we were we were
originally going to partner up I know
that we wanted to and would like to have
a chance to partner up again in the
Ryder Cup and show that we can play well
together and there was some talk of
maybe doing that and then having a
partnership with some younger guys but
when we win it was brought or talked
about amongst David Levy and some of the
television guys they really wanted us to
go head-to-head which I always enjoy
going head-to-head I haven't had great
success but I always enjoy it and this
it's kind of kind of took off from there
the the rivalry I think is what's so
special it's not just that you're both
so accomplished and both so great
there's a history of it can you reflect
on the rivalry and what it's meant to
each of you over the years well we've
gone at it for you know over two decades
and we've certainly had our moments
where we've either has been in tour of
regular tour events or major
championships roll golf championships
we've gone toe-to-toe with each other
and I've always enjoyed knowing the fact
that I was going against Phil over these
years and because I knew that he was
gonna be tough he's gonna pull off shots
that no one's ever seen before
and I'd have to somehow figure out a way
to you know somehow get the job done and
I've always enjoyed it through the years
I know it's been a little bit you know
jaded towards my side so hence I'm
really liking it but you know over the
years it's a it's really been a lot of
fun for me
he was Tiger six years younger than I am
and
even though he doesn't look it he he
would come along and always break every
single every little record so I might
have had some junior records throughout
Southern California he'd come along and
break those I'd go to college I'd have a
nice record there he'd come along and
windows I win a US Amory wins three and
Shadow Creek I shot the course record in
ninety two or three shot 61 he comes
along four years later she breaks it at
sixty I mean it's seemed to be a theme
but Friday there's there's you you got
to do it simultaneously now you can't
come along later you know you're you and
it's my chance after losing so many
majors to you and so many tournaments to
get a little something back what we
witnessed this season especially the
Tour Championship and that mob on hole
18 which was a sight and I think we all
felt that it was nostalgic but it was
also eye-opening at the same time to
factor this into it but also what you
just experienced the story of your
career where do you feel like you are
right now can you put that all into
perspective for us well I've you know
it's been he was an amazing start to my
career the last couple years have been
very difficult
I most people are already know that you
know what I've gone through and
struggling physically but to finally
piece together and get myself a chance
to win that at the Tour Championship and
feel that I held off you know to some to
the best players in the world and to be
able to do that when I hadn't done it
for you know five plus years and to do
it like that and to do it on basically
in my last stroke play event of the
season boy it just meant a lot this
whole year has been been trending
towards that you know phil was alluding
to earlier that he'd won in mexico and
then at tap all of a sudden Here I am
with a chance to win you know I finished
second but you know if you look if I
look back on a noun and in hindsight and
reflecting on it I just think that it
would have been probably too soon to win
but now to have put it together won't
have won the Tour Championship it just
ended the season perfectly
Phil I think the thing that excited me
that most about the 24/7 is your uber
competitor and every time I see you be
interviewed you talk about you hate
losing and I could see how intense
you're taking this I know that they
prepared shadow Creek for you and you
played around do you feel like you have
a leg up do you feel like you might know
this course better than tiger in a way I
think that this has been a very good
thing for me this match because the last
month when I would a lot of times shut
things down I've been grinding I've been
working out every day I've been working
on my game every day and this has been a
great thing from the off season for me
going into next year but to keep my game
sharp and to have a unique opportunity
to do something that I've had a hard
time doing in my career which is get a
leg up on Tiger and anything even if
it's a one-day event like this to have
the opportunity to go head-to-head and
to win is just it's it's great to win
the nine million I just don't want to
lose to him and give him the
satisfaction because the the bragging
rights are what's going to be even worse
than the money it's it's every time I
see you you know I I want to be able to
rub it in I don't want it to be rubbed
in you know I want to sit the champions
locker room at Augusta and talk smack I
I want to I want that as opposed to yeah
I was gonna say I was wondering what the
rent was Tiger says he's been living in
your head for two decades I wasn't sure
if that was affordable or yeah there's a
lot of empty space up there but we you
know there's there's there's been
moments though I mean there's been
moments like and and Grenaa I'm gonna be
stretching here but like the 2012 AT&T
where where I ended up shooting 60 40 or
75 there have been some moments I'd like
to dwell on those I know you're gonna
bring up big picture I get that you know
I know you're gonna bring up masters and
and things like that I get that but and
I have to pick where pick my spots I've
got to be careful yeah I hear US Opens
yeah those two those two
so have fun but but Friday is my chance
to have some fun we've heard about
Phil's preparation Tiger I'm curious
what is your preparation been the last
month for this event yeah after the
Ryder Cup I shut down for about 3-4
weeks and started to you know basically
work on my body and trying to get it
stronger again and I've gotten to that
point so our back practicing sort about
playing starting grind and started
getting into golf again and real looking
for - I was really looking forward to
the break but I'm really far back
playing again
I missed competing and and be able to go
against Phil like this boy gets my
juices flowing for sure when we all
watch golf on television we live for
those moments where the mic picks up
something you say whether it's to the
caddie and we hear a murmur and we write
it on the screen it's on Bleacher Report
in house of highlights and all that now
that you're both going to be mined up
and the caddies are gonna be mic'd up
what are we gonna hear what are we gonna
gain from this experience well I think
it's a for me it's it's the player
interaction but also it's more the Caddy
player interaction that the fans
normally aren't aren't privy to there's
a lot of things that we like Joey and I
talked about going from green to sorry
from tee box to the fairway what where
the flag is what am I thinking about far
as leaving it you know we start wrong
you know we roaming through situations
like that and we do that all the time
that's something I think that the fans
are gonna enjoy and the little side
things that you know for me the the
people who know me plate against me and
I've gotten to know me and play a lot of
rounds with me the little snide comments
I usually make and my breath or or just
just an ear shout so that only the
player would know I think those are the
things that they're gonna enjoy with you
being Mike's - because yours is very
quiet kind of under your breath
understated little jabs and you the fact
that you're gonna be miked
you won't miss those as a viewer and I
think the cutaways where normal telecast
cuts away to commercials I think that's
really the advantage that we have by
getting rid of the commercials and
putting on pay-per-view the fans get to
see and experience something they they
never get to see or an experience which
is those conversations you're talking
about with your player and the Caddy
with with each player walking down the
fairway the some of the challenges that
we might have on the course it's like a
a Tuesday practice round for a
significant stake that makes us
uncomfortable but with the same type of
banter that we are used to that most
fans aren't aren't privy to I think that
I think most people back home I think
the FOMO is real I think the fear of
missing out is real because they're
going to be missing out on a lot of a
lot that they are missing in a regular
telecast and this is the only chance and
it's a unique chance to experience it
the the side actions are the other
aspect that I think I'm very excited
about because when I think of Phil
Mickelson I can only imagine playing
around with you and and and what you're
gonna lay down the action is just gonna
throw me off my game
how strategic have you been in plotting
what you're gonna do with Tiger and I'm
curious Tiger are you having these side
actions ready to go for this event well
for me I have a couple in which I know
that I'll probably place you know and in
spots but I think it's also the heaven
flow on how the match goes if Phil's in
a situation which I feel like he needs
to feel a little bit more heat or he
needs I don't think he I can make him a
little bit uncomfortable and make him
think about what I just said yeah I'll
drop one home and I think that's gonna
be the fun part is trying to figure out
where I can gain an advantage either
through strategy or just timing so so
I've thought a lot about this and
their spots out on the course that are
some great spots for a little challenge
and the challenges are coming directly
out of our pockets okay and I feel like
the first hole is a great hole for me
and I leave in fact I'm willing to risk
a hundred thousand that says i birdied
the first hole so so that's how good I
feel heading into this match you don't
have to take it you don't have to make
it at all but I'm going to further hold
on
so you think you can make birdie on the
first hole I know I'm going to make
birdie on the first all double it did
you see how I baited him like that yes
yes 200 says I heard of the first hole
all right just water down the left he
likes to lose his golf ball to the left
it's a little flare out that he hits see
here's what you're missing
I see - why yes I'm really fun in the
fairway and I'm a great short iron
player fact one of the best if just yeah
number one you like you know sometimes
does its little right as hard to be up
against that tree and he's blocked out
and so he can't spin the ball coming in
that fly oh yeah
and that's how I was able to bait you
yeah first off so that I breathe done
two hundred thousand first hole birdie
so part of its strategic though because
you've got to get them to accept it so
you see how I subtly smooth out in yeah
I didn't know how I was gonna do that
but I think I found the way
congratulations thank you that's at the
perfect time to turn the questions over
to you guys I'm gonna turn it over John
Bush to the PGA he's gonna facilitate
media QA there will be microphones going
around 200 y'all are crazy
and I appreciate that's really yeah
double it up nice all right Thank You
Adam
we'll get microphones to the media if
you'll raise your hand give us your name
and your affiliate please yep let's
start right here second row Jeff Jeff
les with intercut I'd like both your
comments on the odds established by the
local sports books for this a tiger are
basically a two-to-one favorite and
should be labelled
sorry do you say feel about the odds and
are they how accurate they may be I
think they're about right so
strategically what happens here in Vegas
is I don't need to tell you is the smart
money tries to fudge the line and then
then they load up now that it's right
where they want it the line will come
significantly down all right third row
and then Brian behind you
Brian Shapiro from the Vegas take a
question for both Phil and Tiger can you
assure everybody that's going to be
watching on Friday that the loser of
this match will not receive $1 of the
nine million dollars and this money is
not going to be shared upon the two of
you in any way shape or form yeah that's
how it was it's originally scripted and
that's how we've done the deal all right
Brian Brian Hurlburt Las Vegas
review-journal
if I win though I might give him a few
grand just so you know because he's
earned it but that's just me I'm like
that is me but anyway go ahead I'm good
thanks Brian Hurlburt Las Vegas
review-journal
your relationship has evolved
substantially over the years as you sit
there now today what is one thing that
both of you admire about each other most
and the one thing that really annoys you
most about each other well the one for
me the thing I've always admired about
Phil is just the way he's able to
compete and pull off shots that nobody
would be willing to take without you
know hesitation the shot that he played
that you know we all know the shot he
played at 13 and Augusta from the pine
straw I've seen so many of those shots
in person I've been there with him when
he's tried to pull him off and he's
pulled him off he does things like that
and you know over the years what's
annoyed me most is losing foam all right
second row and then we'll go to Chris
Matt rivals house key with Forbes
Phil you mentioned talking trash to
Tiger back in the the day what do you
remember about that practice round from
98 where you've reportedly won a few
hundred bucks off of Tiger and then left
a photocopy of the $100 bill in his
locker
it's the only time in the last 20 years
that I seem to have won those those
matches it's been very rare so I've had
to capitalize and take advantage of
those moments but you know it's been
it's been an incredible opportunity for
me to play my career against him but
it's also been incredibly difficult I
always want I oftentimes wonder what my
you know career would be had he not come
along and I think he could go either way
he's brought out the best of me at times
and it's also been very intimidating
difficult to compete against his level
of play that Matt a practice round was
three or four holes it wasn't a full
round I got lucky and I I'm not I'm not
the best guy to lose to I tend to kind
of rub it in and and and so forth so you
know Friday if I if if and when I win
you know I will continue to rub it in a
lot worse than I did in 98 a lot worse
all right and I'll take it if I don't
know I know I know else man I know all
right Chris and Chris Matthews klas TV
here in Las Vegas for both tiger and
Phil there's been so many great
spectacles in Las Vegas over the years
where you go back to even Evel Knievel
jump in the fountains or Floyd
Mayweather fighting Conor McGregor just
these unusual unique kind of sports
spectacles where would this one maybe
rank in your guys's minds and and how a
shadow crack picked to host this this
deal for both of you please I don't I
don't know how we would compare to those
this is certainly how you know in golf
you tend to play this typical stroke
play 150 guys you play the course but
this is totally different this has the
element of match play of head-to-head so
there's this a bigger amount of pressure
or intensity between the two because
it's a direct conflict whereas on a
stroke play event you go out and
randomly play the course and and try not
to play against your opponent so much
this is the exact opposite this is me
versus him this is winner-take-all and
it's got a very unique special feel that
golf doesn't have all the time it very
rarely has ever had if ever and so I
don't know how it compares to those
other sports but in golf
it's it's unique and different oh great
this is this is very different than
anything golf has ever done ever done in
past I think that's one that you've one
of the unique things about it is that
we're able to showcase our sport in such
a different light and all the different
technologies that we're going to bring
into this event and doing and you know
differently than any other golfing event
has ever been done that's the exciting
thing for not only myself and Phil but I
think that from all the viewers that are
going to watch Jim Daniels NBC Sports
Radio Network this is already we know a
unique event and a unique venue you guys
are already having some fun is there a
chance that this could become an annual
thing and possibly other points around
the world other great golf courses
around the world for this weekend I'm
hopeful that it's received well I'm
hopeful that we provide a glimpse into
the future of what sports watching is
all about I'm hoping that with our
partnership with TNT and bleacher report
that we're having on Xin MGM having on
screen live odds with the potential for
the viewer to be able to wager with the
opportunity to hear banter and and being
miked we're hopeful that this provides
an insight into the sport that is a
glimpse into the future where people
want more and if that happens great then
we'll probably we very well could have
some more if it's if it's if people
don't want like it or want it then it's
probably the one and done but I think
it's a unique special opportunity to see
sides of athletes and sports performance
you've been craving as a viewer and
haven't had a chance to see so I think
it's gonna be well-received
all right let's go to Thank You Dennis
silver CBS sports radio this is for both
of you hypothetically after Friday is
all said and done and you guys both
decided to throw in the towel and never
play competitively again Tiger what
would you say would be Phil's legacy to
the game and Phil what would you say
would be Tigers legacy for the game mine
is easy greatest of all time
that's an easy one for me I've seen him
do things with a golf ball that's never
been done the performance in the 2000 US
Open at Pebble Beach is these single
greatest performance in the history of
the game of golf and possibly all of
sports and he continued to play at that
level for a number of years and the
greatest of all time is an easy slogan
for me with with Tiger you know for me
it's he's one of the greatest players to
ever ever pick up a golf club to go
against him for all these years and see
what he has done he's done it for so
long he's been at the elite level for
such a long period of time there's no
fall offs you know with Phil's game and
there's the fact he's able to win so
many off timers for over two decades is
a testament to how good it really is
because you we all know when we play
sports there's going to come a point I'm
I'm a unfortunate living example of this
is that you're gonna have injuries
you're gonna have moments where you just
can't play it he's can't tee it up for
me cat teed up he can't compete well
Phil hasn't done that you know he's been
consistent he's been been at the elite
level for you know over two decades and
you just that doesn't happen overnight
that doesn't happen very often but where
for me I've been bear witness to all of
this and it's just amazing and how good
and how consistent he's been for such a
long period of time can we just take a
moment and appreciate what a nice thing
you just said about me well you said
that was the last round of golf we ever
play enjoy that Dan buyer Fox Sports
Radio kind of on the heels of that Phil
you talked about on the HBO special
about how it took you a little while to
get accustomed to Tiger when he exploded
on the scene 20-plus years ago but then
we're able to realize what he meant for
you and other golfers what do you think
you meant during your career to other
golfers and Tiger kind of on the heels
of that but what do you think Phil's
game meant to others throughout the golf
world i I don't know that's hard for me
to answer as far as what I've done but I
just know that
in 1997 when Tiger came along won the
Masters he turned pro 96 and the game
took on a whole different meteoric rise
and the person started to climb and the
TV rating started to climb and Golf was
on the front page of the USA Today and
it was a whole different revelation for
the sport on what he's done and I never
imagined when I first started playing
that the golf would get to this level of
relevancy in in the world of sports and
be so well known and have the athletes
be so well known and I still as I look
back can't believe what's happened with
him coming along and it was noticeable
when he was away for a few years and he
comes back and in place so well this
year at the at the British Open the PGA
Championship and finally win the Tour
Championship he saw the reaction and he
brings out an emotion in people that
this sport craves and were very
appreciative of that all right Paul Paul
I hand her with CBS Sports Radio radio
comm for both of you at Phil knowing
your Arizona State days you mentioned
during the HBO special that while you
don't dance very much
you may bust out a certain dance move if
you do emerge victorious over tiger and
then that's the first question for you
for Tiger for you how willing are you to
accept that or have you been practicing
any sort of special celebration have you
not seen what I what I'm not dancing
there's no chance that's not happening
it's intimidating with a guy of my moves
but yeah the the possibility of me doing
the worm is it's possible it's
improbable but possible less than with
other comfortable to you this is
obviously a competition between the two
of you but it's also a business venture
made possible perhaps by your developing
relationship over the years do you see
any future of business endeavors between
the two of you any partnerships in the
future you could maybe let us in on
maybe
owning a professional sports team down
the road or something like that
we haven't gotten that far yet I mean
we're having fun it's fun and games
right now but on Friday it's gonna be
pretty intense and Friday where we're
going to we're gonna we will have banter
but the intensity is is going to be up a
notch it'll be major championship
intensity and we haven't quite gotten to
the further endeavors yeah I mean as she
was just looking to we are focusing on
what we're doing here for the match but
so I mean who knows what the future
holds and if you were to asks us 10
years ago what would be in this position
I think we both would have given a
different answer than we are sitting
here right in front of you and so you
know who knows what the future holds for
us you know with our with our two
different a kyumin's for business and
what we what we like and don't like what
we want to go into in the future you
never know all right let's go third row
and then to the aisle
Brian Shapiro the Vegas take up I know
it's match-play but I guess a two-part
question for both of you what number do
you think you're gonna have to put up to
win this thing and how many birdies do
you think you guys will have to make out
there in order to win this match well I
think there's gonna be a significant
amount of birdies the way the Golf
Course is going to be set up
we're not playing all the t's all the
way back we're a few T 3 a few up T's
and I think the Pens will be in a not
brutal spots and there'd be on a more
accessible side so yes you know there's
gonna have to be birdies made in order
to win holes and to ill win the match
you know how many under I don't know
what that that's gonna be because you
know a lot of it is so dependent on
grant you can get the Golf Course set up
a certain way but if you just get a
little bit of breeze through here it
changes things dramatically so under
normal conditions with like it is right
now you know looking at probably you
know six seven eight nine on our par you
know winning the match but soon as the
wind picks up that all changes and you
know we'll see what happens all right
Matt parole recipe nation radio for both
of you guys you know we know golf
courses around the country on the world
you guys have played in but this venue
being very special here in Vegas but for
people who outside of Las Vegas who
don't know shadow Creek
you just kind of describe what this golf
course is like and what the viewers are
gonna see coming up on Friday I think
one of the most unique places in all of
golf right I mean to go from a flat
piece of property in a flat desert to
creating something that you would find
in the Carolinas out and on you know the
mountains I think it's just phenomenal
the bill would create something so
utopian like this is you know one it's a
testament to the ownership and what
their vision was you know for this
property and what they've done is just
incredible utopia enough is that that's
that Stanford education I went to
Arizona State somebody simple I it I
think it's beautiful what he's done on
this property is spectacular in this
course has always rated one of the
highest in the world it's a perfect spot
for us we were able to bring this event
to Las Vegas and play it on a
world-class golf course and the the the
score will be relevant to conditions and
how the wind is and the temperature and
some of those things but I think we both
have it in mind that this is a sprint
not a marathon we're not playing for
days we're playing one we've got to come
out and fire there's a lot of
risk/reward here a lot of water a lot of
trouble but there's also a lot of birdie
opportunities so I think the the person
that wins is going to probably shoot
seven or eight under par but it could
very well be a lot less to base on the
conditions all right right here at third
row and then Brian Dan Barr again from
Fox Sports Radio did you guys have any
input on course setup and was there any
thought to having it called the match
Phil versus tiger
that was my first loss and I'm trying to
get it back even one-on-one on Friday
yeah that was my girl awesome very good
we haven't really had much input per se
on the setup we wanted it to be you know
fair for both sides so whatever whatever
the tour came up with is great
we are knowledgeable on where the pins
are gonna be so that we're well we're
practicing work and we're not wasting
our time on the entire golf course
there's only one round so we have a
general idea of where where the pins are
gonna be where the tees are gonna be so
that when we practice we're not wasting
our time
all right Bryan Bryan Hurlburt Las Vegas
review-journal for both of you if you
could you've attained a high level of
excellence during your career and
maintained it how do you define the word
excellence and how did you stay
motivated to keep there and Tiger get
back to it I think he's referring to you
because he said excellent so huh well I
for me I think that excellence is is
winning and I have done it since what 96
and Phil's done out what's it's 94 I'm
not money - yeah
anyone in Tucson now you want anyone I
mean so that's to me that's excellence
right there girl from 91 to 2018 and be
able to have have one that's that's
excellent that's doing it at a high
level for a long period of time all
right back left on Tigers deal - on his
excellence he's always played not to as
a competition but just to his own
excellence and that's why he's won so
many tournaments by multiple shots you
know whether it's the open by 15 or
other events by seven or eight the only
you know I played one one the only
tournament that compared for me was the
BellSouth and this wasn't a major where
I won by 13 and those type of moments so
you've done throughout your entire
career where you don't worry about yeah
it's winning but you're not playing
against the other players you're playing
to your own level of excellence and you
have throughout your career so I just
felt like after the nice things he said
about me I want
thank you thank you I think just playing
to your own personal best and and and
bringing out the best in yourself and I
think that's why I'm appreciative of
playing in the Tiger Woods era is that
he helped push me to become my best I
started working out with a trainer to
elongate my career I started I just
started working a little bit differently
more efficiently
I think he's brought out the best in me
because of my my hatred to lose and my
more than even wanting to win he forced
me to work harder and so playing to
again my own personal level of
excellence throughout my career
alright back lift Tiger Phil
Tom Donohue with the Polaris Ages
wouldn't just me I just be a lot more
fun nine million was coming out of your
pockets
well we're going to have multiple side
challenges that are going to be in the
six to seven figures that will be coming
out of our own our own pockets so some
of that is very much true but this event
need to be needs to be for a number that
makes us nervous and and makes us
uncomfortable and it definitely is and
because of that I think both the nine
million that we're playing for along
with the hundreds of thousands and
ultimately a million or two that we're
playing for inside challenges throughout
the match I think that we're it's enough
for us both to feel both to be
uncomfortable and to feel the pressure
well there's 200 right there in the
first hole I don't think he caught the
first part of that Thank You Dennis
again CBS sports radio speaking of the
nine million I've had a lot of listeners
call in and they are of the opinion that
this thing is more about the money than
the game more about the money than
growing the game what do you say to that
well this this event is is
designed to be a unique experience for a
golf viewer and to have an insight into
what goes on with the players to create
a production from drone coverage to on
Sun screen gambling to live mics and
interaction and it's an insight into the
the game that you're not normally able
to see which is why we've chosen each
indecision it's why it's on pay-per-view
because we had to eliminate the
commercials to have that insight in
between the shots it's why we we wanted
to menu we had to create the the
pressure and the tension of a huge event
that and we don't have the history of
the masters or major championships which
is why the number had to be so high
because that creates an uncomfortable
environment for us that creates pressure
and so when you put all those things
together and we've created an experience
for the viewer at home that will be
totally unique and different and
hopefully your viewers will start to
understand and appreciate that and
appreciate what we're trying to do for
them but look it's not for everybody and
if you feel like you're missing out you
probably are because it's it's going to
be something different that you haven't
had before all right we've got time for
one more question
over on the Left Matt pearl from the
traditional radio again Phil this is for
you I also shellcodes pushing the odds
which talks a lot about sports gambling
and you're clearly aware of what's gonna
be happening on the screen I'm curious
from your standpoint Golf in gambling
has gone hand in hand for many many
years before we saw the explosion of
sports gambling here over the last two
years what's your opinion of the growth
of sports gambling with golf being a
major focal point of it so we won't be
aware of what's on the screen and what
the live odds are and so and so forth
we're just gonna be doing our challenges
amongst each other but I think that the
ability to have fantasy golf and to have
live real-time wagering will only
benefit the interest in the game of golf
much like it has in football and the
other major sports and so this is a real
plus I think for golf to capture a lot
of viewership sand a lot of interests
that we haven't been able to capture
before all right thanks
I am having people in the audience right
now asked if like the great boxing
matches if you guys would face off
this can be declined I'm just saying
$200,000 in the first hole Friday 3
o'clock Eastern noon local these two are
going toe-to-toe keep it straight keep
it straight the match 11 o'clock local 2
o'clock Eastern the pregame show new
local 3 o'clock Eastern
Beaty off it's going down and again you
can watch this on BR live and anywhere
that you can purchase pay-per-view Tiger
Woods
Phil Mickelson thank you guys
Tiger against Phil mano-a-mano hates
ahead one day one match